e
[Musique]
[Rires]
peut-être n'y at-il jamais eu autant de
monde que le 1er juin 1958 au palais
bourbon
tous les députés sont à leur banc et
vous conviendrez que c'est une chose
assez rare
impossible de mettre une personne de
plus dans les tribunes du public et la
presse tout cela parce que la tribune il
y à un homme masqué qui lit la
déclaration du gouvernement qu'il
propose aux suffrages des députés cet
homme là tout le monde le sait c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a venu il s'appelle
charles de gaulle un peu plus tard les
députés lui accorderont la majorité 105
voix de majorité
et à ce moment là tout le monde a su en
france et dans le monde que la quatrième
république était morte que c'était une
autre république qui venait de naître
alors j'en appelle au souvenir de ceux
qui sont à même justement de se souvenir
nous avons trouvé ce retour au pouvoir
de de gaulle comme étant le résultat
d'une logique
d'autres ont dit fatalité nous pensions
depuis le 13 mai depuis le coup d'alger
que le résultat serait obligatoirement
le retour de la baule alors heureux il
n'y a pas eu un phénomène d'étonnement
du tout tout cela était prévu
erreur peu à peu on a découvert il a
fallu des moins quelques fois des années
que tout cela n'était pas du tout le
résultat d'une nécessité
en vérité tout cela avait été préparé il
y avait eu dans l'ombre des gens qui
avaient comploté il y avait eu plusieurs
complots
ral l essai par l'effet de ces complots
que de gaulle n'était arrivé au pouvoir
le grand art de le goal c'était d'avoir
ignoré d'avoir voulu ignorer ses comptes
alors justement puisqu'il y à 25 ans de
cela où ils 25 ans cette année
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas qu'il
serait intéressant de suivre ces
complots à la trace et tout commence le
5 novembre 1957
jacques chaban delmas tout nouveau
ministre de la défense nationale appelle
monsieur eugène motte un gaulliste comme
lui lui dit je voudrais vous empruntez
votre directeur commercial pendant un
mois ou deux mois
vous êtes d'accord et notre réponse ce
sera un honneur pour lui et on essaie
directeur commercial s'appelle léon
delbecq
retenez bien ce nom c'est le nom de
l'homme clé de toute cette affaire
alors qui est des modèles bête un fils
d'ouvrier du nord tourcoing
et puis il est on est le bec que a
découvert erreur de gaulle pendant la
guerre pendant la résistance il a été
résistant très tôt il s'est engagé dans
l'armée régulière a été parachuté au
delà des lignes allemand blessé
grièvement et en découvrant
la résistance il a approché de gaulle
par la pensée et il est devenu gaulliste
pour sa vie entière
alors après la guerre il trouve une
situation chez monsieur motte dans sa
filature du nord et il fait toute sa
carrière mais il espère que de gaulle
qui a quitté le pouvoir en 1946
reviendra et il sera du mouvement
gaulliste sans désemparer et en 1957 il
est secrétaire général de la fédération
du nord des républicains sociaux aqesss
que c'est que les républicains sociaux
et bien c'est tout ce qui reste eu du
mouvement gaulliste de 70 députés il
s'en passait en janvier 1956 lors des
élections législatives à 22 députés et
encore le tiers a été élu outre mais pas
très brillant et cela a confirmé de
gaulle dans sa volonté de retraite alors
de gaulle à colombey les deux églises
dans sa propriété de la boisserie
mais dit il écrit ses mémoires de guerre
il va il vient dans son parc qu'ils
marchent suivant un itinéraire toujours
le même qui lui permet de ne pas croiser
ses propres pas
[Musique]
pour le goal ligne à face à lui le
système
c'est ainsi qu'il appelle la quatrième
république
il trouve que ce système conduit peu à
peu la france à la mort mais que fera
t-il contre le système est depuis
quelques temps il y à quelque chose
ganges rennes qui ronge encore davantage
l'état beaucoup plus pour le système et
c'est la guerre d'algérie et c'est à
cause de la guerre d'algérie que le 5
novembre 1957 chaban-delmas enlève léon
delbecque à eugène motte et c'est ce 5
novembre 1957 que commence l'opération
personne ne le sait encore mais elle
commence qui va conduire au retour du
général de gaulle le retour de de gaulle
est lui même de gaulle
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent de ce retour
apparemment il n'y croit pas il est au
plein de sa traversée du désert illinois
de tout quand on vient le voir il ne
veut pas que l'on envisage même la
perspective d'un retour alors aucun
espoir
il a quand même un bureau et li vient de
colombey-les-deux-églises deux fois par
semaine le mercredi et le jeudi
[Musique]
ce bureau et rue de solférino il
entretient une équipe mais oui une
équipe bien sûr cette équipe peut et
bénévoles avec quoi les pays est il
[Musique]
cette équipe chacun de ses membres à une
situation georges pompidou est à la
direction de la banque rothschild
olivier guichard est au commissariat à
l'énergie atomique
jacques foccart vie de l'export import
mais ça ne fait rien ces hommes vivent
pour le servir et olivier guichard
récemment écrivait que c'était entre eux
et lui une histoire d'amour et qu'ils
avaient délibérément choisi la
dépendance à l'égard de le goal et cela
est un signe de grande valeur parce que
ces hommes là sont eux mêmes des hommes
de valeur cela montre que de gaulle
c'est de gaulle alors à part l'équipe il
ya les gaullistes et au premier rang de
ceux ci il y à michel debré
l'inconditionnel type qui ne vit qui ne
rêvent que pour le retour de de gaulle
michel debré qui est à la fois le
saint-just et le savonarole du mouvement
gaulliste et puis il ya ceux que j'ai
nommé les dirigeants du parti des
républicains sociaux il y à soustelle il
y a roger frey qui est le secrétaire
général du parti il ya jacques chaban
delmas qui lui a un peu flirté avec le
système
certains lui en veulent mais ils restent
foncièrement gaulliste
alors ces gens depuis la fin de 56 sont
décidés à opérer la manoeuvre nécessaire
pour que le goal reviennent et ils
savent que l'algérie peut les y aider
prodigieusement mais à propos qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent de l'algérie de gaulle
c'est facile à savoir parce qu'ils
parlent volontiers la lieu dès 1955 il
déclare à jean amrouche écrivain
d'origine kabyle
l'algérie elle sera indépendante son
indépendance est inscrite dans
l'histoire
et quel que soit désormais ses
interlocuteurs ou raymond tournoux ou
louis terres noires ou moules et à sang
le prince héritier du maroc il répète
elle sera indépendant ce qui compte
seulement maintenant c'est de savoir
comment elle sera indépendante et on
sait que lui espère que cette
indépendance se fera dans l'association
mais le coin et les dépendances
ce qu'il ya d'important dans cette
photographie
ce n'est pas la dédicace bien qu'elle
soit probablement ce que je possède le
plus précieux c'est la date 8 janvier
1958 général de gaulle avec lequel sans
bruit j'ai maintenu des relations
épistolaires et personnel pendant toute
la durée le ivème république me convoque
rue solférino à son bureau
j'ai souvent dit que je n'étais jamais
sorti du bureau du général de gaulle a
presque avoir entendu ce que je
m'attendais à les entendre il est
imprévisible comme la grande musique
disait ge
mais là je dois dire que
l'imprévisibilité a été tout à fait
exceptionnel charles de gaulle m'a dit
d'abord mais c'était une coquetterie
je pense qu'il reviendrait jamais au
pouvoir si j'y revenais si nous avions
des institutions garantissant l'autorité
et la continuité la stabilité alors
voici le langage que je tiendrais et
j'ai entendu le 8 février 1958 ce qui
allait devenir
discours du 16 septembre 1959 après le
retour général au pouvoir c'est à dire
je proposerai au peuple algérien de se
prononcer en toute liberté soit pour
l'intégration soit pour l'association
soit au l'indépendance vous savez que
pendant toute ma carrière politique je
me suis efforcé fidèle à l'enseignement
d'un célèbre philosophe de substituer le
mot est homo ou est bien quand la crise
sur moi qui avait été en algérie avec
filin et qui connaissait la pensée de
cible au lieu d'entrer dans le jeu
général des hommes politiques victimes
de l'effervescence du milieu qui en
somme résonnait de la manière suivante
où de gaulle umf imlin je savais qu'ils
étaient fondamentalement d'accord sur la
solution ultime du problème algérien et
j'ai pu me cliquer à les rapprocher n'a
d'autre et le paradoxe le paradoxe
inouïe de toute cette histoire c'est que
les gens qui vont comploté en sa faveur
vont comploté pour garder l'algérie
française est appelée au pouvoir un
homme qui ne croit pas que l'algérie
peut rester français en 1955
pierre mendès france a nommé au
gouvernement général de l'algérie
jacques soustelle
et il a été très mal reçue par les gens
en algérie jacques soustelle parce que
la presse de là-bas le baptiser crypto
progressiste et peu à peu il va se
prendre lui qui est venu partisans de
solutions libérales il va se prendre
d'affection pour cette région ces
provinces pays et pour les français
d'algérie et aussi pour les musulmans il
milite pour l'intégration fait
comprendre aux européens d'algérie que
c'est la seule solution
et voilà que stèle devient l'homme le
plus populaire
[Musique]
et puis quand on le remplace par lacoste
et bien cent mille personnes le
raccompagne
[Applaudissements]
une foule immense il faut un char pour
qu'il puisse approcher de la passerelle
d'embarquement et cette foule immense
chante ce n'est qu'un au revoir
[Musique]
mais le voilà femmes et contre lui qui
est gaulliste qu'on n'obtiendra rien du
système que donc c'est avec de gaulle
qu'on pourra garder l'algérie
comment peut-il le croire lui que de
gaulle reçoit si souvent il sait bien
que le mot d'intégration ne plaît pas au
général mais il pense qu'on pourra
trouver un terrain d'entente avec le
général alors ils préparent les quatre
d'une possible prise de pouvoir il crée
une association pour lons le renouveau
de l'algérie française
les raf il a des troupes des gens qui
adhèrent et un jour quelqu'un disait de
gaulle
soustelle vous ramènera manger leur
alors le goal plus altier que là mais
sachez qu'on n'aura même pas de gaulle
soustelle les soustelle il est de
meeting en meeting va de ville en ville
il rassemble des foules toujours plus
grande appel à ce qu'on garde l'algérie
française appelle à de gaulle tout cela
crée un mouvement et ce mouvement
d'autres gaulliste l'animent
la france ne peut pas tolérer ces
exactions et ses crimes aucun progrès
social
aucune réforme libérale n'est possible
qu'en le sang coule au dessus de toute
politique c'est un devoir national et
humains de solidarité que nous avons à
remplir les algériens de toutes
confessions et de toutes origines ont
laissé des dizaines de milliers des
leurs sur les champs de bataille pour
nous libérer nous avons aujourd'hui à
les libérer de la terreur sans l'algérie
la france serait ravalé au rang d'un
petit pays sans avenir et sans la france
l'algérie serait livré à la nar
sanglante c'est pour éviter ce double
désastre que tous les français doivent
s'unir et pourtant l'année 1957 où nous
sommes c'est une bien triste année la
plus triste peut-être de l'histoire de
la quatrième république
elle commence très mal en janvier
tentative d'assassinât contre le général
salan le général qui commande en algérie
il échappe à la tentative
c'est le fameux bazooka mais l'un de ses
officiers tués et puis la crise
économique est sans précédent les
caisses de l'état sont vides chaque
président du conseil prend l'avion pour
washington pour aller emprunter des
dollars
et puis il ya l'algérie l'algérie à
laquelle léon delbecque réquisitionnés
par chaban va se consacrer tout entier
mais au fait pourquoi chaband at il
demandé delbecq
c'est un ami commun qui le lui a
conseillé vie s'appelle ribot il a
rencontré delbecque en algérie ou
delbecque accompli c'est une période
militaire comme officier de réserve
il a été frappé par sentant
d'observation d'analysé et il a dit à
chaban une faut que vous ayez delbecque
n'diaye delbecque vous seul pour
expliquer au ministre ce que c'est que
l'algérie et c'est pourquoi delbecque
est devenu conseiller technique au
cabinet de chaban chargée des liaisons
avec l'algérie et naturellement il est
allé en algérie
et là il a découvert un spectacle bien
étonnant il a découvert que tout le
monde comploté en algérie
d'abord ce robert martel qui est à la
tête d'un organisme lui fna dont la
volonté qu'on ne perde jamais l'algérie
l'a 15 mille adhérents c'est une force
lui flins alors on ne peut pas dire que
martel désir que l'algérie reste dans la
république parce qu'il déteste la
république à côté de lui il y à un autre
groupement qui s'appelle l'aurore pas
mal d'adhérents plutôt portée vers le
terrorisme ou plutôt le contre
terrorisme
c'est un certain docteur kovacs
d'origine hongroise
l'hypnotiseur qui le dirige tout ça fait
du monde tous là le jour j pourrait
peser singulièrement alors tout ça
paraît un peu folklorique évidemment
jusqu'au jour où a nommé pierre joly un
belge d'origine qui était autrefois
communiste qui est maintenant devenu
tenants de la civilisation chrétienne
occidentale anticommunistes ont peu
changé dans la vie vient trouver martel
et lui dit vous n'arriverez jamais à
rien par vos propres moyens et lui
révèle l'existence du grand tôt oui la
lettre room grands qu'est ce que c'est
que le grand taux demande martel et bien
voilà c'est une société secrète qui est
destiné à prendre le pouvoir en france
est un monde martèle mettez-vous à sa
place et laure joly lui dit si vous
voulez je vais vous faire rencontrer le
grand v qu'est ce que c'est que le grand
v mia chf clandestins du grand o est
morte elle accepte de rencontrer le
grand v se retrouve à bari dans
l'appartement d'un sexagénaire qui est
le docteur mart est ce que cette société
secrète n'était qu'une vue de l'esprit
eh bien pas du tout tout cela avait une
réelle consistance et d'abord par le
fait des deux hommes à qui martin avait
confié le destin de la future révolution
nationale
le grand a et le grand baie et qui
s'était était tout simplement le général
cherrière et ce n'était par yann général
cherrière il avait commandé en algérie
et le granby s'était levé les râles
chasse un cinq étoiles et comme envoyer
ton l'avenir et bien c'est là que
l'association du grand o et de robert
martel pouvait déboucher sur quelque
chose de constructif
on reprendrait le plan d'origine de
martel et un jour les activistes d'alger
marcherait sur le gouvernement général
on appelait ça le gg le progrès d'assaut
proclamerait à alger un pouvoir de fait
immédiatement ce serait le général
cherrière qui prendrait au pouvoir
cependant que dans la métropole grâce à
des complicités qu'on avait dans l'armée
les forces militaires convergeraient sur
la capitale et la tech axa qui
prendraient le pouvoir et créerait un
directoire politico militaire voilà ce
que découvre delberghe mais il découvre
aussi que tous ces gens là ne sont pas
golis on met pas du tout il n'aime pas
du tout de gaulle ils sont même le
contraire de gaulliste pourquoi ben
parce que l'algérie n'a jamais été le
pecq c'est que le jour du clash le jour
où interviendra l'action ces gens là ne
feront rien pour porter de gaulle au
pouvoir
tout au contraire or ce n'est pas ce que
veut delbecque delbecque il est là pour
porter en algérie à travers l'algérie de
gaulle au pouvoir avant de commencer son
action delbecque a voulu voir de vous
l'entretien comme en son temps mal alors
dahlbäck chaban veut gagner la guerre
qui ment c'est pas le sujet que j'étais
venu l'entretenir
je lui brosse
j'essaye de lui brosser un tableau le
plus réel de l'algérie d'aujourd'hui et
des différents composants de cet avis
j'expliquais tout ça au général le goal
m'a écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
c'est bien delbecque et bien fait du bon
travail mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
veut ne pas décevoir
ils me demandent quelques précisions sur
les actions formelle que je fais car je
ne suis pas là seulement m'occuper de
politique je fais autre chose je
m'occupe de la guerre en algérie si cela
l'intéresse également puis il revient
aux sujets développés et d'un air
désabusé il me dit l'armée de lever
beaucoup d'officiers supérieurs ne
pensent qu'à leur avancement sauve pas
les civils
vous le savez delbecq il ne m'aime pas
et ce n'est pas d'hier
les gaullistes que vous avez en algérie
mais c'est une infime minorité suivi à
la métropole hier en métropole ont crié
pour déjà de pouvoir
ne vous bercez pas trop d'illusions
delbecque vous les politiciens ne feront
appel à moi
non croit qu on joue feront au bord du
précipice mais quand nous serons deux
dans l ai entendu l'algérie tranfert dû
depuis longtemps de gaulle se lève
l'entretien est donc terminée il me
prend par le bras et me dit bon courage
telbec rester en contact avec jacques
foccart et puis si effectivement des
événements importants se produisait
n'hésitez pas venez me voir je ne suis
pas un aventurier et doyle est un
légaliste
j'ai l'impression que les choses nous
obligerons l'année l'autre aller plus
loin s'ils doivent se présenter comme je
pense alors la difficulté pour delbecque
c'est de recruter des gaullistes en alu
bien dit lui a dit il ya deux hommes qui
sont les clefs d'alger mario faivre et
le colonel tommaso alors il a vu le
colonel thomas aucune pas du tout
gaulliste il est corse qui les
bonapartistes le colonel tommaso qui est
une figure populaire parce que dans les
guerres passées il a perdu son nez il a
remplacé ce n'est par un bandeau noir on
doit venir de loin celui qu'on appelle
nez de cuir un peu à peu en travaillant
encore tommaso il un qui quand même à
cette certitude si on renverse le régime
pour ne le remplace est pas rien ça ne
vaut pas la peine
et par qui le remplaçait sinon par de
gaulle tommaso fera jamais tout à fait
gaulliste mais à peu près vos listes
alors il a attaqué également le
président des étudiants d'alger
delbecque s'appelle pierre lagaillarde
et puis à l'ail et gaillarde est allé à
paris voir michel debré qui lui a dit il
y aura un clash bientôt et puis quand il
rentre à alger justement tommaso
delbecque with your un clash alors ça ne
plaît pas à pierre lagaillarde qui n'est
pas gaulliste non plus et d'écouter le
coup d'état polichinelle le monsieur
chaban delmas
moi j'en suis pas ne comptez pas sur moi
et pourtant à mesure que les semaines
passent la certitude du clash approche
telbec on est convaincu qu'on ne ça ne
peut pas durer plus longtemps ça va
éclater sa va éclater en algérie alors
il repart et repart il va voir de gaulle
nous sommes à la fin mars 1958
je le trouve très ouvert et coopératif
il a eu le sens d'être informé et cela
dans les moindres détails
mais moi aussi j'ai besoin d'être
rassuré un certain nombre de choses et
même j'ai besoin d'avoir des certitudes
je lui lis mon général il est possible
que des événements se précipitent
j'ai l'impression que tout peut arriver
là bas imaginez un instant que les
musulmans les européens appellent le
général de gaulle que là mais les vous
soutiennent et les soutiennent et que la
métropole accepte de faire appel à vous
à ce moment là mon général quel serait
votre position
nous sortons pas de la légalité mais il
y un appel à google général alors tome
de ses lèvres une réponse que je
n'oublierai jamais si on fait appel à
moi dans ses conclusions lb alors je
répondrai présent
vous pouvez compter sur moi on peut
compter sur moi et quand delbecque s'en
va il a des ailes mais en se prêtant de
1958 de gaulle continue à affirmer à ces
animaux qui ne croient pas sans retour
andreas tout va le voir et lui dit qu'il
sent que l'opinion évolue que l'opinion
va l'appeler est alors de gaulejac ses
grands bras vers le ciel et 10 illusion
illusions ont pedu lui dit aussi que
indiscutablement de l'opinion lui est
beaucoup plus favorable que quelques
mois plus tôt mais pompidou ajoute c'est
un mouvement je le crains en général qui
ne durera pas et de vaud lui ai dit
c'est mon avis pour pitou puis reconduit
pompidou et pose la main sur le bras ni
quand même si je reviens contre si on
vous ment pitou
c'est le temps où les états unis et la
grande bretagne ont frôlé leurs bons
offices pour finir la guerre d'algérie
c'est un tollé dans l'opinion française
un tolet bien plus grand en algérie vous
pensez bien
et c'est encore sur l'algérie que le
gouvernement de félix gaillard balle
tomber et moi showman va dire ce jour là
et si c'était la dernière crise de la
quatrième république une suscite une
manière de scandale il a raison alors
rené coty va appeler georges bidault qui
tentera en vain de former un
gouvernement après quoi il appellera
rené pleven haine qui échouera lui aussi
à former un gouvernement
et ça dure plus de vingt jours une
interminable crise ministérielle en
pleine guerre d'algérie alors que tout
le monde sent qu'il va se passer quelque
chose de grave en algérie et le
discrédit de ce régime qui augment qui
est évident de plus en plus vive de plus
en plus profond quittera alors delbecque
a compris quelque chose depuis un
certain temps des heures de vol n'est
pas populaire en algérie c'est évident
en revanche soustelle l'air et
l'admirable tactique de delbecque c'est
d'avoir voulu partir de ce moment-là
jouer de la popularité de soustelle
plutôt que de celle de de gaulle il se
rend compte que s'ils amènent des genres
à soustelle il amènera en même temps des
gens et de bol des gens qui ne seront
pas tous vents à lebon en allant
résister
[Musique]
delbecque sait très bien qu'il peut pas
faire bande à part
il n'est pas ravi de s'associer avec les
activités mais il le fait quand même et
on va préparer ensemble une grande
journée le 26 heures
pourquoi pour rien simplement pour
montrer sa force et on appelle les
algérois manifesté devant le monument
aux morts et ça marche très fort
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de gens
se réunissent au monument main et jure
que l'algérie restera toujours française
et delbecque qui suit son idée
n'abandonne jamais fait à plusieurs
reprises crier vive de gaulle mais oui
on crie vive de mort
et voilà c'est que lacoste le ministre
résident et le général salan en ont
assez de ce delbecque depuis le début ne
comprennent pas ce qu'est ce qu'il vient
faire ce delbecque qui est soi-disant le
représentant l'antenne de chaban delmas
mais on n'a pas besoin d'antenne de
chaban delmas
ils ont demandé ni fois le rappel de
delbecque et finalement lacoste et
adressée au président de la république
lui-même rené coty et l'ordre de revient
de paris
il faut que delbecque sand et le soir
même du 26 contrat est forcé delbecque
doit quitter alger par avion mais
l'antenne la fameuse antenne de la ville
là elle pillards et bien cette antenne
la sudiste
voilà le delbecque à paris et là son
activité littéralement foudroyante il
voit d'abord le général elie chef d'état
major de l'armée le chef suprême de
l'armée française ne peut pas s'engager
comme ça à l'instant dans une
conspiration il est prudent mais il
renvoie delbecque qu'à ses adjoints le
général de beaufort et le général petit
qui eux marchent à fond le 27 avril
delbecque appel lucien neuwirth un
stéphanois l'ancien compagnon de gaulle
combattants valeureux de la guerre ago
liste qui lui apprend qu'il doit faire
une période militaire à saint maixent
comme officier de réserve
et delbecque d'un trait de plume modifie
période et on voit le vert' à alger il a
besoin de mes virages et puis le 28
avril jeu j'ai été reçu par le général
de gaulle auquel je l'étais exposer nos
états d'âme c'est à dire notre certitude
les choses près pas continuer à les
longtemps dans ce camp soit isolée dans
notre pays que nous vivions une fan
république et nous espérions bien le
voir revenir en le général s'est montré
de très très dubitatif a débuté pied au
croyez vous que les choses vont changer
comme ça
la femme en général on est convaincu qu
en algérie ça se passait quelque chose
aux idiots et en algérie
on voudrait bien qu'il ya quelque chose
avec un bigeard avec de bishr n'est pas
avec de gaulle
on n'est pas contre de gaulle nom n'est
pas pour de gaulle le golem en général
je fais partie d'une génération à
laquelle vous avez appris qu'il fallait
croire contre toute espérance
nous nous croyons c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pars là bas faire ma période
je vais expliquer ce qui se passait ce
que nous avions mis en place et on
ferait d'audience générale s'est levé
m'accompagner à la porte de ce bureau de
la rue de solférino et ça m'est resté il
avait sur la serrure et la mêlée mais
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
finalement quand je dis moi général on
fera appel à vous il ya eu un silence
les me dit je vous répondrai et c'est
comme ça que j'ai eu le sentiment
partagé d'ailleurs à nos amis pour
dalmat et quelques autres
c'était une sorte de presque de ce ver
qui nous était donné mais en face
c'était une autre interprétation et nous
pour la première fois il a eu l'air de
s'engager à une verte est parti saisit
est arrivé là-bas à alger la rencontre
et tommaso nez de cuir et a pu nouer en
quelques jours toutes les liaisons
nécessaire
et puis l'activité à paris de delbecque
continuer rencontre chaque jour tous les
dirigeants gaulliste une passe de
soustelle à debré à michelet moi je
ferai à des châtiments
et c'est le moment où tous nous tout se
lit on met sur pied à travers la france
des gens sur lequel on peut compter
soustelle utilise ses anciens compagnons
de la résistance et puis d'autres et
puis les liaisons avec l'armée s'opère
de plus en plus précise on sait sur qui
on peut compter en sait qu'on peut
compter sur le général michael dans le
sud-ouest le général michael qui dispose
de parra
le jour j on aura peut-être besoin de
parra sur paris et puis on dispose aussi
de la force blindés du colonel reviews
grévistes qui est venu appeler par
delbecque et par pouget lors d'un
précédent voyage rue saint dominique et
qui a reçu ses ordres directement de
petits et de beaufort
tout cela se met en place et puis le 8
mai le 8 mai delbecque n'y tient plus il
sait bien qu'il est interdit de séjour
en algérie tant pis il faut qu'il soit
là ça peut être l'été d'un jour à
l'autre et lui d'elbe et n'y serai pas
ce serait une catastrophe il prend
l'avion le voilà alors après l'échec de
rené pleven n le président de la
république rené coty va faire appel à
pierre film
et d'emblée les socialistes refusent
leur participation à pierre tible alors
d'un seul court les lacoste
si populaire à alger et koné et lacoste
va partir il va partir presque
clandestinement
personne ne l'accompagnent
et le même le général salan adresse au
général elie pour être remis au
président de la république rené coty un
télégramme très grand dans lequel il dit
au nom de toute l'armée française
d'algérie l'angoissent de cette arme
dans lequel il appelle à la formation
d'un gouvernement dont on puisse être
sûr qu'il gardera l'algérie c'est la
première intervention de l'armée
d'algérie dans la situation politique
française du moment c'est le 9 mai que
le fln fait savoir qu'on a fusillé trois
soldats français prisonniers ceci dit il
en représailles pour la fusillade de
prisonniers du fln par les français
alors une explosion de colère on imagine
bien tout alger se soulèvent de colère
et delbecque vient de reprendre l'avion
pour paris il est en voyages incessants
entre paris et alger parce que toute
approche tout se noue l'instant c'est
pour tout de suite et dans l'avion il
apprend qu'on vient de décider à alger
une gigantesque manifestation pour le 12
mai ce sera la manifestation celle dont
tout peut découler
alors il est en liaison directe de son
avion avec alger et il persuade par
radio les gens d'alger de reporter leur
manifestation au 13 mai parce que le 13
mai c'est le jour de l'investiture
réclamé souhaité par pierre film il vaut
mieux conjuguer les deux choses et là il
par redoublé d'activité pendant son
séjour parisien nouveaux contacts avec
l'armée
et puis dans son bureau de la rue saint
dominique
il reçoit l'état jon reçoit le
commissaire de police
il faut s'assurer de leur collaboration
le jour j il reçoit les gens du sdec il
reçoit les officiers de gendarmerie
ça marche ça marche même très bien et le
12 mai au soir il prend l'avion pour
alger où ils arrivent dans la nuit
et le voilà le reste le fameux 13 toute
la matinée à l'antenne non-travail
telbec qu'à retrouver ne vire et tommaso
époux jay les autres et il apprend au
cours de la journée que les autres
conjurés les activistes
le comité 17 et bien ceux là sont en
train de le doubler
parce qu'il reste toujours cette
antinomie entre gaullistes et non
gaullistes et les autres sont de moins
en moins gaullistes et des cibles sur le
coup pour même pas pour de gaulle
ils se méfient de plus en plus de le
voir les voilà ce qui est décidé à rose
heures du matin au comité 17 et bien à
la manifestation quand ça lancera venu
eh bien on aura un grand drapeau et
quand on lèvera ce drapeau est bien on
foncera tous sur le gg le gouvernement
général lors dès le début de l'après
midi déjà la foule s'achemine vers le
square laferrière là où se trouve le
monument aux morts vers 4h ya des
dizaines de milliers de jours
17h30 ya au moins cent alors c'est
difficile de venir nous sommes et c'est
patrick alors les gens se voudra plus
d'encre il ya des micros l'algérie
abandon non non non françaises halle
berry française et voilà à 18 heures
salle ans qui arrive avec sa suite au km
car discipline il s'en va 18h et à ce
moment là martèle robert martin qui
tient le fameux drapeau dont la hanche
s'est brisée dans l'accord lève sans
drap et c'est une rue et un rush vers le
gouvernement général
[Musique]
hélas les grilles sont fermées il ya les
crs
la camion et ce camion font sans marche
arrière sur les greens qu'il brise et
voilà qu'hier la gamme ya dix ans
en une minute il mettra plus minutes on
le voit arriver au balcon du
gouvernement général en tenue d'apparat
il n'y a pas droit mais il lié et il
lève le bras et la foule cette foule
immense qui l'acclament et qui
s'engouffre dans le gouvernement général
et les machines à écrire qui volent par
les fenêtres et les dossiers et les
papiers delbecque il était passé parce
qu'il est coincé par la foule impossible
d'avancer
curieusement ce n'est pas lui le
gaulliste qui arrivera le premier c'est
un autre gaulliste et son ami neuwirth
pour aller au gg c'est impossible
une foule immense et finalement grâce à
une de nos amis qui nous l'avait indiqué
qu'ils étaient au bled au journal le
bled
nous sommes passés avec une petite
équipe de circulation tiers une équipe
militaire plus une sonorisation
d'important nous sommes passés par un
souterrain qui reliait directement le le
cinquième la cinquième région et le
grand général le gg il trouve la porte
du souterrain
ils rentrent mais il ya une clé il
referme la porte derrière lui en porte
la clé on ne sait jamais et le voilà qui
arrive dans le bureau central aux côtés
de pierre lagaillarde et des tas de gens
qui sont arrivés de partout et qui
continuent à arriver
voilà robert martel gags qui a pu
prendre la poule et il tombe à 6
été soufflée et les autres midi et les
chefs lui arrive parce qu'on a toujours
parlons de source
n'oublions pas le grand a le grand baie
et martel attend le général serrières il
n'est pas là et martel dit oui on
attendait le chef ils ne sont pas
arrivés et les gaullistes n'ont rien non
plus ils n'ont pas de chef parce que
delbecque aurait voulu que soustelle
l'accompagnent alger le 12 mai au soir
mais soustelle à dinan je dois être là
demain pour le vote d'investiture
depuis moulins je veux que pim là ne
soit pas investie à part le wirth qui
est là et qui n'est pas un chef il n'y a
personne n'y a pas même delbecq
alors là comme est insensé tout le monde
parle et voilà que lé là gaïa intervient
il faut créer un comité de salut public
salut public le grand mot est lancé
et puis voilà le général massu qui parle
général massu chi la figure la plus
populaire d'alger massue ses coûts fram
c'est le serment de koufra avec le
clairs c'est strasbourg encore avec
leclerc c'est suez c'est la bataille
d'alger qu'il a gagné l'alluré typique
caractéristiques du baroudeur et qui
arrive qui vient d'arriver comprend pas
il dit qu'est ce qui se passe il
engueule la gaillarde unique est ce que
ce que déguisements propos tenus par a
et puis l'appel colonel il montre la
foule nettoyer moi ce bordel
comment nettoyer le bordel plus facile à
dire qu'à faire
et la gaillarde qu'il y amasser un
comité de salut public il y tient son
comité de salut public à n'ont pas de
militaires a dit mathieu et puis alors
la gaillarde ifo d'emilie théâtre les
civils massu fini par se laisser
convaincre neuwirth a apporté avec lui
un micro un amplificateur en haut
parleur mais quand la gaillarde a voulu
prendre la parole et bien curieusement
tout était en panne c'est à dire que le
vire tout est pour quelque chose dans
cette pâle et alors le comité de salut
public on dresse une liste on demande à
ceux qui sont là qui réclame enfin
pratiquer ce que vous représentez
qu'est-ce que tu représentes mais moi je
représente tel quartier moi je
représente les anciens combattants est
un type qui ne représentent rien et on
lui dit mais qu'est ce que vous
représentez vous la foule ça c'est une
belle réponse alors on laisserait tout
de suite
[Musique]
et quand mme à suva la lire que cent
mille personnes qui sont en bas et bien
miraculeusement neuwirth est l'auteur du
miracle le micro bar marche alors on
entend la voir
tony cotte y pense un plat nation et
puis voilà le général salan vient aux
nouvelles lui aussi mais quoi qu'est-ce
qui se passe
d'ailleurs il a voulu prendre le
souterrain et il est resté devant la
porte close
il n'y avait pas l'appeler il a fallu un
quart d'heure pour qu'on trouve une
autre alors ils estiment le ranimer quoi
qu'est ce que c'est alors on m'explique
qu'est ce qu'il peut faire le général ça
il faut qu'ils consultent sans
gouvernement
à paris on est en train de discuter ça
fait des heures au parlement à la
chambre des députés qu'on discute sur
l'investiture de pim là mais vous savez
la règle quand tant qu'un nouveau
gouvernement n'est pas nommé c'est
l'ancien qui expédie les affaires
courantes à la salle en appellent l'ex
président du conseil fait d ailleurs lui
raconte la situation
ainsi paris ne comprends pas moi je je
reste mais je n'accepterai pas
d'entendre contraire et je le dis du
reste et monsieur gaillard alors à ce
moment là me fait envoyer leurs messages
téléphonés télégramme ainsi conçu
général salan a maintenant la
responsabilité des vies et des biens de
l'algérie
je suis donc si vous l'a intronisé ce
que je deviens responsable dès les 8
heures du soir d'y manger dans
l'assemblage je prends la faire un an
compte puisqu'on me donnait à
responsabilité salon veut annoncé à la
foule qu'il allait pouvoir du
gouvernement et puis la foule lui on ne
veut pas de salon qu'on ne passe à lons
de pâques des talents et on entend
massue massue massue alors salon refait
le numéro du président gagneur allô
monsieur le président ils veulent pas
moins un vol de macias est une très
bonne idée dit fed et du gaia vous
n'avez qu'à subdéléguée vos pouvoirs au
général massu admirable énergie d'un
régime agonisant
alors on annonce à la foule que c'est
massue qui a maintenant les pouvoirs
acclamation voilà l'affairé fait la
faire et gagner et c'est à ce moment là
seulement qu'arrive delbecque qui a pu
franchir les barrages et delbecque qui
se présente je suis l'envoyé de jacques
soustelle au site on l'inscrit sur la
liste du comité de salut public ça fait
beaucoup d'effet jacques soustelle mais
salon lui qui est à son bureau le
reconnaît et lui dit oudin un voyou
delbecque delbecque ne se décontenance
pas expliqua salon à tout prend que la
seule solution c'est de gaulle salon le
pogo liste
il n'a vu de gaulle que deux fois dans
sa vie une fois à mulhouse en 1944 et
puis à colomb béchar l'année précédente
une aucune attirance particulière pour
le groupe mais il est là s'il est
fatigué comprend pas ce qui se passe
et puis le général salan est un homme de
bonne volonté c'est un homme qui cherche
sincèrement et la pièce sans acquiescé
est ce que c'est un coup d'état qui est
fait en tout cas cet accord et on
l'apprend à paris et aussitôt par voie
de conséquence son vote à tous de 8 est
l'investiture à petit bhl qui ne
l'auraient pas eu sans sa robe films
l'un est face à une algérie devenu
dissident
il est face à une opinion qui l'accusent
avant même qu'il ait pris le pouvoir
en tout cas qu'ils accusent de région
une opinion qui le fuit comme elle fuit
le régime film là va présider pendant
quelques jours 1 100 tonnes de
gouvernement et ces efforts pourraient
être parfaitement ridicule la situation
est ridicule
mais pierre pfimlin honnête homme
réussir à ce tour de force de n'être
jamais à aucun moment
ridicule et pourtant il sait bien faible
on l'a formé dès le premier jour
son ministre de l'intérieur lieu moque a
été informée car entre temps les
socialistes ont fini par accepter de
rester dans le gouvernement
une moc c'est tout ce qui se prépare il
sait les mouvements militaires qui
peuvent éclater d'un jour à l'autre il
sait que départ ap atterrir venant
d'algérie d'autres venant du sud-ouest
il sait tout cela philippe blain le sera
jour après jour les informations
viendront sur son bureau et il
gouvernera il tâchera de gouverner avec
cette terrible épée de damoclès sur la
tête
et c'est lent à alger mais il a pris la
tête du mouvement
mais il s'est pas prononcé formellement
pour de gaulle en tout cas pas en public
dans la foule vient de couleurs
c'est un rite sous les fenêtres du
gouvernement général et le 15 mai ça
l'ennuie pas delbecque qui prédit parce
que delbecque capri portage de ne plus
quitter salon et il termine son
allocution par heure vive la france vive
l'algerie france elle déterminer comment
sa mort c'est demi-tour mais delbecque
qui est derrière lui
lui pointe le doigt dans le dos et lui
dit toumba crier vive 2 go réflexe
automatique salon se retourne vers le
micro écrivent ville d'abord la foule
est tanné stupéfaite reprend vite devant
et 2go justement est bien de gaulle est
dans l'expectative depuis le douce parce
que ce jour-là le général elie a adressé
au gouvernement une lettre qui est un
avertissement très grave est d'ailleurs
le général elie va démissionner s'il y
avait eu insurrection coup d'état
militaire putsch prononce yamato s'il y
avait eu du sang qui aurait coulé dans
les rues de paris
jamais de gaulle n'aurait accepté de
rentrer mais là il estime que l'appel
officiel du délégué officiel du
gouvernement français kessal ans il peut
l'entendre et il répond par un
communiqué qui va produire très
exactement
l'effet d'une bombe atomique je me tiens
prêt à assumer dès maintenant les
pouvoirs de la république et j'en
appelle encore à vos souvenirs à ceux
qui est en âge de vous souvenir quand
nous avons entendu cela à la radio quand
nous avons lu nos journaux nous avons
été convaincus que quelque chose
d'historique était en train de se
produire
mais voilà c'est que le gouvernement la
majorité qu'il soutient personne n'est
disposé à laisser passer de gaulle et on
se débat dans un cercle vicieux
a alger des lmex inquiètes se dit que on
est dans une situation trop instable il
ne pourra plus de tenir à lui tout seul
avec une poignée de gaulliste et
soustelle et bien soustelle après
l'investiture aurait voulu s'en aller
mais on l'empêchent de son année la
police ne suit ne le quitte pas d'une
semelle
alors il va réussir une évasion on va le
faire monter à l'arrière d'une voiture
le recouvrir d'une couverture la police
n'y verra que du feu ils se retrouvent
en suisse dans un avion dont l'algérie
il est le 17 mai à alger a clamé
follement voix séparent mais vous en
veux tu as pas rendre main à notre
magnifique armées d'algérie j'ai décidé
de revenir à alger
au milieu du peuple aux côtés de l'armée
j'ai choisi tout à la fois la liberté et
la patrie veux bien me mettre à la
disposition de l'algérie française
je n'ai pas d'autre intention que de la
servir cependant cette situation est
encore instable alors entre ce
gouvernement cette majorité qui ne veut
pas encore de de gaulle et de gaulle qui
attend l'appel
que va-t-il se passer eh bien il se
passe le 19 mai le 19 mai de gaulle
annonce une conférence de presse et le
19 mai il est au palais d'orsay
jamais on n'a vu tant de monde au palais
dorcé ils sont venus de partout les
journalistes
la conférence de presse sera retransmise
partout même en amérique
aurillac est là qui dit à son fils l'a
dit une journaliste américaine qui
dionne la grossir à illéla à suivre il
le matin trois années le désir de voir
lors de notre dernière rencontre
si vous vous en souvenez je vous avais
fait part de mes prévisions et de mes
inquiétudes quant aux développements
probables des événements voilà pourquoi
le moment a semblé venu où il pourrait
mettre entre possible d'être utile
encore une fois directement à la france
et puis après la déclaration liminaire
et voilà les questions et on la terreur
sur la poste il il accostait mon ami et
leigh bowery guy mollet pour l'un de mes
compagnons il s'est battu
ce sont des choses qu'on n'oublie pas
les pouvoirs de la république quand on
les assume
ce ne peut être que ce qu'elle même est
ce que j'ai jamais attenté aurait pu au
liberté publique fondamentale
je les ai arrêtable et liège une seconde
attendez jamais comblé ou qu'à 67 ans je
commence une carrière de dictateur
[Musique]
la classe et il repart il que leur
pardon son village pour attendre ce
qu'on vit dira ce qu on lui répondra
alors on sait très bien qu'il faudra que
pim la scène la place est un combat de
retardement et maurice schumann va voir
films l'un qui est son ami politique ils
ont milité tous les deux dans les rangs
du mrp de pire des maux pour un pays
c'est la guerre civile je suis l'ami
intime de bien filmé l'unc et mon
successeur à la présidence nationale du
mouvement républicain populaire et je
suis est toujours été gaulliste moi
c'est de rapprocher les deux hommes et
je sais que ce n'est pas un rêve ou plus
exactement je sais que les vrais réalise
dans les grandes circonstances ce sont
les rêveurs apa et voilà que le jeudi de
l'ascension début de l'après midi puis
un film là me convoque et me dit j'ai
bien réfléchi je ne verrai pas de gêne
et hambourg j'ai un motif pour cela j'ai
les ministres socialistes dans les
grandes circonstances il faut se référer
les principes moraux essentiel tout film
l'un c'est pourquoi je les aime tant et
dans des propos de cet ordre il ne
tolérerait pas une rencontre donc il n'y
aura pas de rencontre je me précipite à
neuilly chez imbert frère john
chavagneux directeur général de réalité
publication à laquelle je collaborais
très régulièrement à l'époque sécher
frères gens que je rencontrais olivier
guichard intermédiaire conséquent avec
cette réponse olivier guichard est un
d'une extrême courtoisie d'un très grand
calme et je vois qu'il a le plus grand
mal à se maîtriser
auxerre ne perd pas son sang froid il
devient blanc il me dit c'est trop bête
et il ajoute et bien dans quinze jours
le colonel il je me rappelle le nom mais
je préfère ne pas citer sera ministériel
et à ce moment là se produit un
événement extraordinaire heureusement
que tous les témoins sont encore vives
et pourrait confirmer mon propos s'il en
était besoin
une fillette edwige frère jean qui est
aujourd'hui la fin de mon nom ses
collaborateurs aux yeux non tu ailles
représentant de la france auprès des
nations unies à new york
elle avait douzaine d'années dit d'une
voix tranquille pape ans on demande
monsieur guichard au téléphone c'est de
la part de monsieur guy mollet qui
charment regarde il n'a rien à me dire
nous sommes parfaitement compris pierre
films l'un par loyauté envers ces mini
socialistes refusent un contact avec de
gaulle et ce contact direct par dessus
la tête de films là il est pris par les
ministres sociale
je me précipite à l'hôtel matignon
je rapporte la conclusion de mon
entretien le soir a eu lieu
l'entrevue entre le général de gaulle et
pierre pflimlin qui a permis à ce qui
apparaissait comme un rêve de devenir
une réalité à savoir la constitution
d'un gouvernement de gaulle et
l'établissement d'un cinquième
république
à l'intérieur de ce gouvernement
figurant antoine pinay pierre jean et
guy mollet et bien filmé leur a compris
lui aussi et il accepte de répondre
favorablement à la demande que lui
adressent de gaulle d'une rencontre
alors là aussi ce sera un peu comme dans
un western il faut que tu fumes la dgde
piste les journalistes
des immeubles à double issue et
finalement se retrouvent le soir du 26
mai à saint-cloud dans la maison du
conservateur du domaine de saint-cloud
monsieur bruno et bien regretter à
saint-cloud c'était ma couverture qu'un
destine et j'avais amené mes mains parce
que les allemands qui occupaient avant
moi mais tout emporté la conservation
était absolument sans aucun sens aucun
mobilier lancé m'accuser ras des cils
voici le fauteuil que j'affectionnais le
général et à chaque fois qu'il venait il
avait ses habitudes il prenait ses aises
à la maison alors d'un premier qu'est
venu nous retrouver et et flynn la
présidence rimains est venue un matin un
matin c'est à terre très tard dans la
nuit
j'appelle ça le matin vers 2 heures du
matin il est venu et je dois dire que le
président un flou ne part pas très fier
les alentours du domaine était triste au
possible rien était éclairé les portails
d'entrée était encore en bois
c'était un aspect assez désolant et je
comprends que mes visiteurs n'ai pas été
toujours très content de venir dans un
lieu aussi sinistre que celui là est la
voie la pfs imlin et de gaulle face à
face avec des positions encore très
éloignées film là avant tout avant toute
négociation veut que de gaulle condamne
la sphère d'alger l affaire de corse oui
parce qu'entre temps les gens des
leviers ont tenté une opération sur la
corse l'an réussi alors filmé le voeu
que de gaulle condamne tout ça et de
gaulle refuse de condamner tout ça je
dis m'écouter soyez logique
l'homme qui a commandé à tout cela le
général salan et bien c'est le délégué
officiel du gouvernement français
alors vous voulez que je condamne le
délégué du gouvernement français c'est
très habile comme réponse est aussi
c'est une tactique efficace parce que
comment pourrait-il les condamner
puisque sans eux
son retour ne pourrait être envisagée
alors on va se séparer après 2h inutile
et de gaulle repart alors c'est venu le
grand espoir c'est fini à 10 heures le
lendemain matin jules moch ministre de
l'intérieur reçoit racontera-t-il des
informations très précises et
circonstanciées le débarquement est pas
et pour la nuit prochain et à 10h15 de
gaulle de colombes et dicte à son bureau
de paris un communiqué le communiqué
fameux qui commence par ces mots j'ai
entamé le processus régulier pour
l'établissement d'un gouvernement
républicain le processus régulier qui de
se souvient de cette phrase les journaux
vont paraître on le résume ans je me
souviens de ce titre sur toute la page
de gaulle de pointe j'arrive il est
impossible de revenir là dessus mais
rené coty le président de la république
en est le premier certains et le 10 à
primelin qui n'a plus qu'une chose à
faire démissionner ce qu'il fait
gouvernement ne faillira pas à sa part
il fera respecter les lois de la
république et les exigences du alors on
va traiter avec de gaulle mais comment
obtiendra-t-il il y a un horaire à
mettre au point un plan d'action
alors côté aimerait que ce soit l'ancien
président de la république vincent
auriol qui rencontrent de gaulle pour
mettre tout cela au point orioles se
dérobe
alors on décide que ce sera le trocquer
président de l'assemblée nationale et
monnerville président du conseil de la
république c'est-à-dire le sénat qui
iront voir de gaulle nouvelle rencontre
dans le même lieu à saint cloud 23h et
d'emblée ça se passe mal parce que le
troquet referee jo république elle
rempli de préjugés à l'égard de de
gaulle d'abord en entrant lui dit vous
savez je ne vous appelle pas mon général
vous appelle monsieur le président
commence mal monnerville leur joint et
le trocquer très énervé agite son unique
bras l'autre il l'a perdue à la guerre
précédente en disant c'est impossible
edit d'abord il faut que vous consultez
je ne consulte ray pas idéaux sont vous
rendiez l'église traditionnelle aux
présidents de l'assemblée et du conseil
je ne les ferai pas des mots
il faut vous présentiez votre
déclaration l'investiture à la somme je
ne nierai pas à l'assemblée gondry il
faut que monnerville calme les choses
mettent de l'huile dans les rouages et
finalement de gaulle ou laissent
entrevoir que peut-être il erra
l'assemblée mais tout cela n'est pas
très certain et de gaulle prend congé en
disant si nous ne tombons pas d'accord
et bien je rentrerai définitivement avec
mon chagrin dans mon village
alors le lendemain matin de nouveau mené
la danse un cul de sac
et c'est le président de la république
rené coty qui va dénouer la situation le
président de la 4è république n'a aucun
pouvoir
la constitution ne lui donne pas le
moindre autorité
et oui il va violer tous les usages il
va prendre parti lui même et il adresse
un message au parlement et à 3 heures le
trocquer furieux et on le sent dans sa
voix il n'est obligé de le lire devant
tous les députés debout
le message
dis-donc coty qui commence ainsi j'ai
fait appel au plus illustre des français
alors maintenant tout ira très vite
19h temps de vol areva l'elysée tout le
monde l'attend par l'entraîneur où sont
honorés les normes l'année dans la liste
il déjoue tout cela et coty aussillon le
fait entrer
de l'autre côté par la grille du coq
deux heures plus tard tout est au point
tout est d'accord de gaulle accepte
quand même d'aller lire sa déclaration
devant les députés
[Musique]
il y sera le premier lieu il obtiendra
sa majorité
deux jours plus tard il retournera à
l'assemblée pour enlever auprès des
députés à qui il sera par les admirables
m la mission qu'il veut détenir redonner
une autre constitution la france
et le voilà qui arrive dans sa voiture à
l'hôtel la pérouse chaque fois qu'il
venait à paris toutes les semaines ce
mercredi ce jeudi il descendait à
l'hôtel la pérouse et naturel mallet le
portier le même portier albert c'est
jean ferniot qui a recueilli histoire
albert qui lui ouvre la porte et il sort
de la voiture et tape sur l'épaule
d'albert sava voilà j'ai gagné mais le
mot de la fin
le véritable mode la face et léon
delbecque qui va leur accueil
léo delbecque qui devant le triomphe
était couru à paris pour baigner dans ce
triomphe lui qui a presque tout fait et
de gaulle le regarde
bravo les mecs vous avez bien joué un
petit silence mais moi aussi les le bec
j'ai bien joué
[Musique]